is there a tension between a living wage
and maybe you could speak to what a
living wage means and the workers owning
all of the profit of the company
instead of uh this kind of spectrum no I
guess the spectrum is from
like no no minimum wage the lowest
possible thing you could pay to a worker
than somewhere in that spectrum is a
living wage and then at the at the top
is like uh all of the profit from the
companies owned by the workers
so split to the workers
I mean I think that any society is going
to have to make distributional
um choices
um you could have imagined a variety of
capitalism in which workers are paid
quite little but there's extremely high
taxation and there's redistribution
after the fact you can imagine a system
in which there's less taxation after the
fact but there's more guarantees and
regulations to how much people are paid
before the fact
in my vision of a social Society there
would be some other way that unions work
and in my exempt these centralized uh
bargaining Unions would work that
bargain at the sectoral level and not
just at the Enterprise level like our
unions do do today
um
there could be benchmarks set for
different occupations or wages and the
reason why you would want to Benchmark
at a worker controlled firm is that you
don't want workers self-exporting
themselves in order to gobble up market
share or because you don't want them
collectively deciding okay we're going
to invest in this longer term time
Horizon and out compete other people
that way so you might say okay if you do
this sort of clerical work you have to
be paid the equivalent of 15 an hour
that's a minimum but on top of that you
get
um you get uh you know dividends from
from excess profits
um and I think it would also have to be
combined with
um public financing for expansions and
for development which could be done in
quite a competitive way so you could
have a variety of of banks you know in
my vision you know state-owned Banks but
what how would they decide who to
um invest in and who to not and invest
in who to give a loan for expansion to
and who not to because you don't want it
to be like Oh I'm going to invest in my
my nephew's firm and not this other firm
or I'm going to invest and this guy's
firm because he's an Italian but not
this guy's firm because he's Albanian or
whatever else just make it rational at
the level of their goal is just like any
other
um investment person at a bank today to
maintain a certain risk profile and to
have an interest yield and decide to
invest on on that basis so if there's a
huge Automotive firm that has been on
business for 50 years that needs a
little operating cash like yeah they
could get their 50 million dollars their
three percent loan if you have some
crazy blue sky idea and you manage to
get it to that that point like maybe you
new friends would get it at you know 12
or something close to whatever VC would
offer today so I only kind of go into
these details not because to say that
a system doesn't have to in advance
map out all the different possibilities
but I think it does have to be willing
to accept a lot of things we know today
you know I can't give you a version of
socialism that's everything's going to
be fine we're going to live harmoniously
and we won't have these sort of tensions
and you know you could hunt in the
evening and you know fish in the you
know afternoon and write criticism you
know whatever else
um I do hope that there's Horizons
Beyond this that we could aspire to I do
have those Visions but for now I think
our task as socialists is to imagine a
you know five minutes after you know
midnight like what what can we do right
away within our lifetime
um Vision so that means
through some level of central planning
reallocating resources to the workers
so I think the primary mechanism in this
private sector under socialism would be
a market mechanism firms competing
against each other to expand uh
connected to a system of public
financing but even at that level the
individual
um bankers and and public Banks and so
on will be operating based on their own
rationality
and the state would certainly shape
investment decisions but maybe no more
than they do in a lot of capitalist
systems so the state might already today
and a lot of countries decide
you know we want to invest in Green
Technology so it's going to be favorable
rates for people or tax credits for
people investing in Green Technology so
the state already shapes investment
um I think what should be centrally
planned and this is where like I'm proud
to sound like an old school socialist is
things like um Healthcare things like um
Transit things like our
um natural monopolies of lots of types
uh you know I think can be done very
well through
um through planning and we already have
plenty of examples but a lot of this
Society I think would be would be the
the private sphere of worker controlled
cooperatives uh competing against each
other weak firms failing successful
firms expanded